the death of Iron Man in Avengers ends
game was as heartbreaking as a superhero
death can be and actor Robert Downey jr.
was a mastermind behind one of the most
wrenching aspects of Tony Stark's
passing as fans know Tony Stark
sacrificed himself during the final
battle against Thanos at the end of
Avengers and game after retrieving the
Infinity stones just as everyone thought
the mad Titan had them in his possession
Tony let's Thanos square in his big dumb
purple face declared and snapped his
fingers Thanos his army of Chitauri his
Black Order sycophants and his fleet of
spaceships all crumbled away to space
dust marking a big win for Earth's
Mightiest Heroes it came at a cost of
course in the form of Tony Stark's life
in the last few seconds before he died
slipping away due to the damage he
suffered from using the Infinity stones
all Tony could manage was a faint hey
pep when Pepper Potts came to say
goodbye
devastating for sure but not quite the
enjoying final words would expect from
Iron Man
so why didn't I a man have any official
dying words and Avengers endgame
according to screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely it was Downey
Jr's idea to not complicate Iron Man's
death with any final lines after I am
Iron Man in order to make the moments
that much more impactful it explained
during the San Diego comic-con 2019
panel that a previous draft of the end
game script saw Tony chattering away as
was typical for the cocky hero but
Downey jr. didn't think it felt right
McFeely explained these actors have
spent a lot of time with these
characters so Chris and I are very happy
to and did write all sorts of lovely
dying words for Tony Stark Robert is not
happy to say them right Robert wants to
and knew this instinctively that Tony is
a guy who was talked and talked and
talked for many many movies when he
doesn't talk you are crushed and he knew
that and we didn't feel we could turn a
page where he didn't talk ultimately
Downey jr. told McFeely a marker said he
wanted to quote do much much less with
Iron Man's death which McFeely admitted
was the absolute right call in the end
Tony Stark's passing an Avengers end
game went through multiple rewrites one
of which was drastically different than
even the version where the hero was
talkative as he slouched over and
knocking on death's door one draft of
the scripts that actually made it to
shooting saw Thanos Pizza Iron Man I'm
inevitable and the armored Avenger snap
his fingers without saying a word
game directors Joan Anthony Russo shot
that version of the scene which was in
tax all the way until the editing phase
of production before editor Jeff Ford
suggested that Tony say I am Iron Man
Downey jr. was originally opposed to
livering any kind of line even one that
calls back to the iconic confession
scene in 2008 sia man when Tony Stark
reveals his superhero identity I am Iron
Man and it took some convincing for the
actor to come back for reshoots
thankfully ends game producer Joel Silva
who is an old friend of Downey Jr's was
present at the dinner where the Russos
pitched the new idea and was able to get
Downey jr. on board Tony Stark may have
been a hero who lived and died by quips
as Avengers end game director Joe Russo
once said but it's hard to imagine his
death going any other way than it did
the scene wound up striking the perfect
balance between a powerful full-circle
moment with a I am Iron Man line and a
minimalistic approach that offered a
crushing contrast to Tony's chatty
nature and this largely thanks to Downey
jr. check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]